hello belief nation this is volume three
of a new episode that I am testing out
where we take some of the best footage
that you guys have really enjoyed from
the past week or so from the channel and
mash it up into one video for you guys
it's on the fence if I'm gonna keep it
or not so let me know what you think let
me know if we should continue watching
it and I hope you enjoy also as you guys
watch this video if someone says
something that really resonates with you
don't forget to put it in the comments
with quotes around it so that other
people can be inspired as well I didn't
have a rich father not from you know
well-educated I said I tried three times
for university all filled for the last
time I went to the Teachers College
which was considered the third or fourth
class of my city but I think that is the
best university I've ever had
better than Harvard and Wharton I
applied for harbor for ten times all
filled they don't want to see me you
know terrible
and I I think that is a normal life
right and I believe that it was so
difficult at that time I was so
frustrated because I taught in the
university my pay was ten dollars a
mouth what's not easy but I believe that
something something is waiting for me
there and I have to work hard to prove
myself so that was the tough experience
and I never thought I was smart nobody
believed that I could be successful
because everybody said well this guy
think differently think of crazily you
know they think about something never
worked in 1994 disgust said I'm going to
do something called Internet and 23 of
them against it they said this is stupid
idea right we have never heard about
Internet and you know nothing about
computer why you want to do the computer
so no but I agree with as I said I
believe it because I saw the computer in
1994 when I went to the USA I think this
thing could be big but I never thought
it would be that big like today honestly
people say you're smart you have a big
vision 1994 since he has sought Internet
that was not true I just want to find a
job because I could not find a good job
so I do myself so that is the history
that's the thing and now after 16 years
we have a lot of we have Alibaba Group
we have a team or group we have a
tarball group well Felipe and people say
how you make it
why this make it why people cannot have
fun opportunities you can find
opportunities and I think people same
here today Jeff where is the opportunity
I don't have a job I don't have this I
don't have the debt I remember 20 years
ago ice I hate a Bill Gates I say he
took all the job you know Jesus
great Larry Page Bill Gates and every
success people they did good and why I
don't have this chance the same question
like you later I come down myself and
luckily I win I tell you unlucky to know
a lot of famous people Bill Gates Warren
Buffet the Jack Welch Larry Page Mark
Zuckerberg I know all of that I would
like to share with you that those people
the difference between those people and
other people they are always optimistic
for the future they never complain
they've always tried to solve the
problems of the others and I think where
is the opportunity the opportunity lies
always lies in the place where people
complain some people sit there complain
you think if I can solve that complaint
that's the opportunity that's what I did
and I think nineteen ninety four ninety
nine is five so many people in China
want to sell things abroad but there's
no place because the big business can go
to the trade affair Las Vegas fair and
Germany fair small business they don't
have opportunity so they complete we
want to go the trade shows but they
cannot get visa they don't have money
they don't relationship so I think if
Internet can help this small business it
will be great but nobody would have
believed it
why Internet can help well I said if if
something everybody believed it
everybody loved it
forget about that's not a good
opportunity because where everybody
agrees why this opportunity should be
yours because a lot of people don't
agree with it and you think this is good
think carefully and find a group of
people working together and making sure
the people working with you together the
the dreams whether investors believe it
this or not whether your friends believe
it or not whether your parents believe
it or not that's not important you
believe it your team believe it and work
day and night on this that's what the
things happens right my investors do
nothing after 10 years they invest in us
they still don't know what I'm doing
honestly people say why are you jack you
have such so many great investors yeah
they are great because they believe jack
mark can do something but what exactly
is doing they probably don't understand
but we have to know we know the only
thing I'd tell you guys for the first
three years we do not have even one
dollar revenue from our business but why
it keeps on going ahead going forward
because I received lots of email of
thanks from the customer they say this
is such a great thing if you can keep on
doing that we cannot pay you but this
thing helped us if you keep on helping
us one day you will be successful and I
believe this don't worry any mistake is
an income is a wonderful revenue for you
so I taught myself and told my young
people before 20 years old be a good
student
way too entrepreneur just to learn some
experience before 30 years old follow
somebody go to a small company normally
in a big company it is good to learn
processing you are a part of a big
machine
but when go to small company you learn
the passion you learn the dreams you
learn how to do a lot of things as well
one time so before 30 years old it's not
which company you go it's which boss you
follow it's very important a good boss
teach you differently and before from 30
to 40 years old you have to think very
clearly were you working for yourself if
you really want to be interpreting when
you're 40 to 50
so you have to do all the things that
you are good at
don't try to drop into the new area it's
too late you may be successful but there
the rate of dying is too big so forty to
fifty think about how can focus on
things that you are good at but when you
are 50 to 60 years old work for the
young people because young people can do
better than you
so rely on them invest on them making
sure they're good so when you guys over
60 years old spend time for yourself on
the beachside shine right it's too late
for you to change novelty but this is my
my advice to the young people 25 years
old
make enough mistakes don't worry you
fall you stand up your forest and enjoy
it I'm at 25 years old I sure enjoy the
show
to make the actual making of a film the
day to day go into work the construction
of them has always been my favorite
thing I like making it feel much more
than I like watching them I do and even
the ones I'm in I really love the coming
together with a whole bunch of people
having an idea on paper and everyone's
got everyone's an expert at what they do
and your and you're off on this journey
you've got ideas but then you just let
him you let it let it go and see what it
can become
I love the making that's when I'm
happiest is when I'm making a film or
telling the story the day-to-day and
more so than watching him really the I
mean look I kind of define that for
myself about four years ago process
probably stay in process head down in
process stay in your bubble and when
it's over be that fulfillment notice
when I started I said that fulfillment
of it I just finished well that's enough
that's it I don't know if this thing I
don't know if it's even coming out I
don't even know I don't know what it's
gonna turn in man I hope they I hope we
got it and I hope the director put
something good together but I don't know
nothing I can do about that all I know
is this experience that I said go have
the experience Makani and if I can love
this experience and at the end of it I'm
I may never even hear that film again
may never even know that story again it
may be gone let me find out that all the
negatives cut fried the x-ray machine
there is no film but I've gotta be
that's okay I had an experience when I
got selfish for that for that experience
when I got that process enjoying that
process the day to day architecture of
making a movie in creating a role that's
that's what I've been the happiest and
more results have come that way in an
odd way you know but I just saw when I
started really approached them as this
is a finite thing and this is just that
experience
other than that I'm not producing this
thing I'm not the one that anything I
don't know what it's gonna be that's it
and then all of a sudden they come out
and go oh I think he's got a good one so
are you surprised by places you went in
that performance are you surprised when
you see it back or are you not at all
ready
not after I engaged and not after I took
the dare soon as we I got off the phone
call with him and then also when he said
it's not in the picture now but we think
I think it'd be great at Dallas dance at
the end and my heartbeat went up on the
phone and I started breaking the cold
sweat like oh no I thought that's not
and as soon as I wouldn't all no that's
not that the other other metal in my ear
said dare you do and I just meant of
course I think it's yes cuz I
immediately notice if you don't you
listen out dude are you kidding me you
will forever regret you have to so as
soon as I got over that I was like well
that's inevitable I'm doing it mmm now I
got to bust my ass to go do it the best
I can and a lot of fear that I mean that
was yeah that was that was some major
really good anxiety and fear and then
now we're saying now I'm saying by that
time now everything my choice is from
that phone call long work anything I was
nervous but you have to go no don't go
all I go meet midnight yes can y'all
meet him for another Corey choreographed
session 8:00 a.m. Sunday morning do you
got an hour
I'm gonna go send them here my wife's
over there why
- reading something understanding the
mirror I'm gonna practice as a move this
is really embarrassing well too bad man
do it in the mirror right now because
the less embarrassing that gets
hopefully the more comfortable you'll be
when you're out there in front of 80
people a m-- bunch of cameras and one
thing you do when you go out there don't
come up short yo go all the way
practice faithful persistence means
never ever ever give up Chicken Soup for
the Soul was rejected by a hundred and
forty four publishers 144 publisher said
we don't want to publish a collection of
short stories the title stupid Chicken
Soup for the Soul what does that mean
people don't buy collections of short
stories there's never been you know
successful chain of doing that so
literally we spent 14 months trying to
find a publisher and we go to New York
with our agent and eventually our agent
gave us the book back and said I can't
sell this so we went to the National
booksellers Association convention down
in Anaheim
we went from booth to booth to booth for
three days and there were 4,000
publishers represented there there we go
would you publish a book would you
publish a book would you publish my book
and we got no no no no no it was late on
the third day that a little publisher
from Florida after we'd gotten over 144
rejections said we'll read it and then
they said we said well how many copies
do you think we'll sell after they said
yeah we'll buy it a couple weeks later
he said we'll publish it and we said
they said well maybe 20,000 if we're
lucky and we said we our goal is to sell
a million and a half in a year and a
half now have you ever told someone your
dream and had them laugh out loud of
here
he laughed out loud now if we had given
up after a hundred publishers had said
no I wouldn't be standing here today
you know wouldn't have happened and so
you've got to be willing to persevere
because we didn't take no say when the
world says no you say next let's
practice that if I say no you say
absolutely there's only five or six
billion people out there you can go and
ask right there's over four thousand
publishers just here in the state of
California so what we have is this
endless possibility but you have to
persevere it's as if the universe tests
our commitment and so today we have a
hundred and forty seven titles in print
we sold over 115 million copies
we're in 47 languages and over a billion
dollars where the Chicken Soup for the
Soul books have been sold worldwide so
if you're willing to decide what you
want believe it's possible consciously
envision the future feel the feelings of
what it would feel like if you'd achieve
this goal
you could have anything and then you
take action both obvious actions and
inspired actions you can do anything
one of the the functions of belief is
taking action we did a survey of about
2,000 top entrepreneurs and we noticed
that one of the things that people who
win in that world have is a bias for
action if they have an inspiration they
act on it I mean how many of you have
ever had a great idea talked about it
thought about it didn't do it and then
someone else did it and was successful
and you went darn I should have done
that maybe it was by that piece of
property it was all that we all have
that piece of property we wish we'd
bought you know anyway so we're gonna be
looking at the idea that taking action
is part of Law of Attraction see a lot
of people think you just sit in your
room meditate visualize having the
perfect car the perfect house the
perfect relationship and then it'll kind
of just come to you and I always say
unless you live at the bottom of the
hill
where there's a road it's probably not
going to be a Cadillac show up in your
living room right so think about this
the last six letters of the word
attractions fell what a CTI Oh in action
now there's two kinds of actions that
are critical there's obvious actions if
you want a certain kind of car you
should go down and test drive it you
should find out how much it costs you
should see what it costs to maintain it
you should go you know spend I like to
test drive a car three or four times go
down to the dealer take a camera stick
my head out the window say take a
picture of me I'll be back to buy it put
it up on my refrigerator look at it
every day eventually you know those kind
of things produce car right saving for
it and so forth but there are also
things called inspired actions all of a
sudden you get an inspiration to do
something and you didn't know what it
was you don't have a sense of like how's
this rationally gonna make sense for me
to move forward in my life I'll give you
an example a friend of mine dr. Ignatius
Piazza graduates chiropractic school he
wants to move to Monterey
near Pebble Beach where the golf course
is and he gets there and he says to the
local Chiropractic Association like to
join you and like you to help me get my
practice started and they said we don't
need anymore chiropractors we have one
chiropractor for every eight people in
this area as too many now he could have
said okay let the external reality
control his internal experience but he
doesn't do that he said I'm gonna think
about this and visualize it and believe
in it and something will come that I
will do and what came to him to do was
to take six months before he opened his
office and put a pin where he wanted his
office and then concentric circles knock
on every door in every neighborhood
saying hi I'm a new doctor in town could
I ask you a few questions you know I'm
starting this practice should I open
from 5:00 to 9:00 in the morning and or
should I be open from 5:00 until 9:00 at
night for people who have nine-to-five
jobs which would be better should I
advertise in this paper or that paper
should I call it Ignatius Piazza
chiropractic or chiropractic West then
his last question was the five an open
house would you like to receive an
invitation they said yes he wrote it
down now over six months he knocked on
12,500 doors
talked to 6500 people and gathered over
4,000 names of people who said yes I'd
like an invitation you're open
now when he opened his office six months
later in a town that did not need
another chiropractor according to the
professionals his first month in
practice he netted seventy two thousand
dollars in his first year in practice
his gross income was over a million
dollars I was giving a talk and
mentioned this story just about five
years ago and this happened about 25
years ago someone said he knocked on my
door and he left his card and two years
later I needed the chiropractor and I
called him because we work with people
we know we've had an experience with
right so he trusted his intuition he
took action on it other people would say
oh if I can't have what I want you got
to be willing to take the action if
you're going to be successful in
creating the life of your dreams you'd
have to believe that you are capable of
making it happen you have to believe
that you have the right stuff and that
you're able to pull it off now whether
you call it self-esteem self-confidence
or self assurance
it's a deep-seated belief that you have
what it takes the abilities the inner
resources the talents and the skills to
create your desired results now
believing in yourself is simply an
attitude believing yourself is a choice
you have to choose to believe that you
can do anything you set your mind to
anything at all because in fact you can
it might help you to know that the
latest brain research now indicates with
enough positive self-talk and positive
visualization combined with proper
training coaching and practice anyone
can learn to do almost anything now I've
interviewed thousands of successful
people and almost every one of them has
told me I was not the most gifted or the
most talented person in my field but I
chose to believe that anything was
possible and because of that I studied I
practiced and I worked harder than the
others and that's how I got to where I
am
you know if Ruben Gonzalez a 20 year old
living in Texas hot Texas can take up
the ludes which is a winter sport and
become an Olympic athlete if Bill Gates
who is a college dropout can become a
multi billionaire and Steven J Connell
who was a dyslexic student
who failed three grades in school can
become a best-selling author and a
television producer then you too can
accomplish anything if you'll simply
believe it's possible so make the
decision right now to believe that you
create all of your experiences because
you do let's start creating the ones you
want by believing you can sounds a
little strange but accepting this level
of responsibility is uniquely and
inevitably empowering it means you can
do change and become anything at all you
may think that something as small as
being optimistic won't change much about
your life have you ever heard this line
just because I'm paranoid doesn't mean
the world isn't out to get me now that
may be a joke but many people believe
the deck is stacked against them people
who are reverse paranoids otherwise
known as optimists use the same
consistent thinking but they believe
that the world is plotting to do them
good everything that happens is pushing
them in the right direction
this attitude breeds more good thoughts
so why not practice to become a reverse
paranoid start seeing obstacles as
opportunities to grow and change when
your presentation doesn't get the sale
see it as an opportunity to create a
better presentation and become better at
your job see the task that gives you
some power to change rather than the
failure that makes you feel powerless
look for the seed of something better
when everything is going wrong
almost everyone sees getting laid off is
a bad thing but even if you want your
job to be over the end always feel sad
not inspiring
the end of one job however always holds
the promise of the new beginning of the
next job if you look at it that way
you're focusing on what a reverse
paranoid thinks about identify the great
benefit in every event soon you'll start
to see that good is not an accident but
something you create with your attitudes
walk through your home your business
your apartment your condo anything
you're in charge of and make a list of
all the things that aren't exactly the
way you want it there's never a stapler
by the Xerox machine someone always
leaves that cabinet open my kid never
picks up after himself those pictures
are always slander they never stay
straight the screen door slams there's a
hole in the window you know whatever it
is write it down and then go back and
here's the key part
remember in law of attraction we always
focus on what you want not what you
don't want you don't want to be going I
don't want a man of smokes I don't want
a man who watches TV all weekend I don't
want a man who yeah cuz that's what
you're gonna get
alright because what you focus on is
what your track so you want to focus on
the opposite so what you want to focus
on is the opposite of your irritation
list there'll always be a stapler by the
darts machine we solved it in our office
with a little chain and some glue it
doesn't leak okay but the key is there's
always solutions the pictures that won't
stay straight velcro right through the
wall no on the bottom it works you know
but the point is you want to get a list
of what's the outcome you want and then
take a day hire a person or hot you know
bring a friend over and go through the
list and get as many done as you can you
know all the easy ones build some
momentum clean the garage develop a new
filing system that might be something
you'd you know set off to another
weekend and we say all the big ones that
are really big do one a quarter every
three months
solve one of those now you're getting
rid of all the stuff in your life and
why is this important we're talking
mostly about being wealthy having great
relationships great health world peace
ending hunger and you're talking about
the screen door when you don't fix the
screen door you settle and when you
settle consistently you develop a habit
of settling for what you don't want and
most people go through life in
resignation
they've resigned themselves to not
having it the way they want it here's a
stat from from your show and it's just
the richest 85 people on this planet
have as much money as the poorest 3.5
billion yeah right
on the planet however sex it's not far
off - in America no it isn't far off in
America but we still and we still here
don't abandon the idea that it isn't
finite yeah
it isn't finite if you were born where
were you born me yeah
Baton Rouge Louisiana batteries General
Hospital there you know Louisiana I was
born in Memphis Tennessee had a long
haul from where I came from to here but
here we are right so proof is in the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
and here we sit the dining table
but it's hard to when you say that to
some people because they say oh there
you go with a pull yourself up by the
bootstraps thing and you know you're
just being respectable not everybody can
do that
look everybody can everybod it doesn't
courage courage is the key to life
itself a lot of people who are born in
situation of uh survive just I'll never
get out of this so they won't I say to
people say well I would like to have
done so and so and so so you could have
done it so but I couldn't get out of
here man the bus runs every day exactly
right yeah you exist if they're if
they're if you can conceive it in your
mind if you can think of it you can do
that's a human condition and we can
imagine that we can do it right and I
think that the the condition of each
individual human your job as an actress
to give it your best shot
each every time so yes I'm going into it
with the idea that I'll play it to the
best of my ability and they wouldn't
give it to me
the role if they didn't think I was
capable of pulling it off oh I wouldn't
take it if I didn't think I was capable
of pulling it off I was just thinking
about you and I was going over the story
of your life and what you think your
mission is like do the purpose everybody
tries to find their purpose if you
figure than able to articulate to
yourself what it is no I don't have a
purpose and I think it's it's
unnecessary for each individual to have
create or anoint their own purpose life
has its purpose our business is to see
how well we can fulfill that that's what
I like about we tie well because so much
about anything that spiritual or
religion applies so much value to the
self as opposed to just experience where
it's already there we are just a piece
of life if this can become a
full-fledged life that's all it is it's
just that because
there is no sense of balance and joy and
peacefulness in people people are trying
to find a purpose and always a god-given
purpose and what makes its individual
think that God is giving you a
particular purpose right it's a large
creation in your consciousness or the
physical purpose like in the way that an
ant serves a purpose in the ecosystem
consciousness is our own thing
consciousness is not our own thing know
what I mean in terms of like people
sometimes you know you do your job as a
physical being and that might be your
job
what's the immediate purpose right now
right but that's it so what do you think
that are you talking about just the
physical being are you talking about
something else so this is what when
people are looking or when people are in
pursuit of happiness they are trying to
do specific things that they like if
your life is an expression of your joy
then you're not looking at what you can
do you're looking at what is needed and
you do that well I think that's
everybody's business in this world what
is most needed right now if we can do it
joyfully that's all there is I want to
fulfill my whim and you want to fulfill
your whim and there's a whole lot of
problem we're doing a whole lot of
unnecessary things on the planet because
we're in pursuit of happiness rather
than being an expression of joy I'm
wondering when you're trying to make a
film and you come up against obstacles
and barriers what do you attribute your
strong dedication to getting that film
made um really I this area usually
hysteria and obsession and anger I think
mainly anger I'm mad all the time
might just you know angry angry angry
pain in the neck that's why I use humor
a lot because it deflates myself I don't
want to take it seriously because I
really do you I would have been gone
much longer I had 25 years ago today I
wouldn't survive but the anger is
enormous but everything about everything
and so that also fuels me to make a
picture I think
but keeping the sense of humor is the
key thing the irony oh the irony when
you get there in the morning and you get
a note that one actors have it rhythms
breakdown and you can't go on with the
film it happened it happened yeah they
don't want to come out of the trailer
right here what you're gonna get a heart
attack otherwise or you kill someone you
know it's not good without meaning to be
presumptuous what sacrifices do you
think you've made in order to create the
work to make the films to make the
career that you've done what do you
think in your life you've sacrificed I
think you know as an old friend old
priest told me said you pay a price you
know when you pay a prices I just quite
honestly you know a personal life really
and relationships go by the board I mean
it was as if the Frank Capra quote it's
like being like a drug or something that
you have to continue and now as I say
some people call that drive some call it
obsession some call just being selfish
and being not a very nice person
but the reality is that I just had to
continue that process what do you do
when you when you change how the world
thinks of cinema what's next I mean do
you keep making the same kind of film or
a few person like Rosselini if you are
yeah you try something experimental you
push further
that's just experimental experimental
experiments sake but you push the
boundaries further I grew up with no
self-confidence no self-esteem I kicked
it was kicked out of school several
times I misbehaved I ended up spending
half of my school in the library cuz I
was kicked out of courses I left school
in the 12th grade and got a job as a
dishwasher worked as a labourer lived in
my car dug ditches and things like that
so I had no self-esteem and I began
studying the subject over the years and
I found that your level of self
confidence how much confidence you have
in yourself to be do accomplish
something really determines the whole
quality of your life so what I found is
that there's a direct relationship
between how high your level of self
confidence is and your level of sales
one one relationship between self
confidence and selling success because
in selling you've got to be bold you've
got to be courageous you've got to take
rejection and disappointment you've got
to get out there you've got to face all
your fears in order to get appointments
you've got to face your fears in order
to ask for orders so self-confidence is
critical self-confidence is essential in
business because it's impossible to even
a start
business to arrange a bank loan to set
up customers to hire people to do all
the things that are necessary in
business requires self confidence also
what we found is that your level of self
confidence is the critical factor in
your level of sex appeal is that the
more confidence you are the more
appealing you are to other people the
more confident you are actually the more
magnetism you have that's why actors and
actresses who seem to be extremely
confident have a certain amount of
magnetism so confidence only is really
important for us it makes us feel happy
it affects and empowers other people it
causes people to treat us differently we
make more sales we make more money we
marry better we're better and more
effective socially self-confidence is
everything
the easiest way to build self-confidence
there's no magic button I can't say this
plane is going down who can fly it put
your hand up I can I'm confident
repetition repetition repetition right
what does Malcolm Gladwell call it the
10,000 hour rule there's no magic button
and I recruited a goalie from Colombia
South America one year I big tall six
foot three man you know he had hands
like stone I thought he was like flipper
every time I throw him the ball down
down onto the ground I was like oh my
god we're in trouble
simple solution get to the wall kick a
ball against the wall and catch it kick
the ball against the wall and catch it
his goal was 350 a day for eight months
he came back his hands were callused the
moisture on his hands were literally
gone he is now playing in Europe magic
no repetition repetition repetition the
problem is we expect to be
self-confident but we can't be unless
the skill or the task that we're doing
is not novel is not new to us we want to
be in a situation where we've created
we've had so much pressure in that and
what I mean cuz pressure builds diamonds
we want to be in a situation where hey
I've done this a thousand times I did in
my speech I practice in front of the
mirror
hey I'm sounding good and then I read in
front of my kids and my and my wife is
like oh my gosh a little nervous then I
get in front of Glenn cool oh my
goodness I'm a little more nervous by
the time I get to the ACG we're 2,500
people can't say any more right 2,500
people
we're 2,500 people are there I won't
have a single ounce of nervousness
because of my ability to practice right
over and over and over again
the problem with repetition is how many
of us bail after the first a bit of
failure
how many yes bail after the first bit of
adversity Edison was on that video it
depends who you ask is anywhere from one
1,000 to 10,000 tries to build that
lightbulb 1,000 to 10,000 JK Rowling's
should be on that video you do I'm a
publisher she took her Harry Potter book
- I believe the number was 12 or 13 I
don't I'm pretty confident but after two
or three noes I'd be like
after six or seven I'm like maybe not
definitely after nine or ten I'd be
looking to be a soccer coach or
something else beside it often right I
mean twelve times somebody said no but
practice practice practice and do not
accept failure maybe it shouldn't be
repetition maybe the answer should be
persistence because we all repeat
something but very few of us really will
persist so that's one way to build
self-confidence get out there do what
you want to do and accept do not accept
null another technique that you can do
physically and that's to simply change
your physiology and when I say
physiology I'm talking about your
posture
I'm talking about your head up I'm
talking about your head straight
maintain eye contact that automatically
sends a signal to you of being more
confident try it out if you're slouching
in your chair right now if you're
sitting on your couch like this watching
this video take a moment
sit up take a big breath breathing helps
as well a lot you have 80,000 messages
that transfer up your spinal cord into
your limbic system into your brain that
sends signals to your prefrontal cortex
that allows you to make effective
decisions now that's a miracle of
machine problem is most people are
hunched over like this working at their
computer all day they're not moving
enough then they go to they sit in their
car then they come home then they're
watching TV again it's ridiculous
elevate your posture my friend lift it
up maintain eye contact put your head
back roll your shoulders back and allow
those signals to enter your brain so
that you can make effective decisions
and overall feel more confident because
how you feel what how you feel dictates
who you are it's all energy it's all
vibration in your emotion it's a whole
world out there man that believes in
what you can do and what you can say and
the energy you bring you know I'm not
even just justify myself a lot of people
have their own different necks and you
know you don't have to be a super
lyricist or story to it just be the
energy you bring you know saying they
believe in it but the moment they feel
like you don't
even that no more and you just going
with the next trend where this aid
awaits or whether there's an up tempo or
slow tomorrow true exactly
they don't believe it you know more you
know the coach you don't believe that
you know more so stand behind what you
do and you know the world is gonna move
by and that's not you gotta look at it
if you don't like to look themselves in
the mirror that's the hardest thing to
do you know it's to critique yourself
rather than pointing a finger you know
and then everybody hates change
so to actually do that and say I'm wrong
in a lot of areas I look at myself in
the mirror and I'm sounding wrong in a
lot of Eros it takes a lot of willpower
you're doing saying so it start with
self first the nickname they've been
acquired since I was a kid just being in
the neighborhood know something given to
me by just my homeboys growing up in
Compton so that name always good you
know I'll go back to your city now No
I just felt like it was a time for me to
grow you know not only as an artist but
as a person I want to you know the world
to know me who I am and I just said back
and reflect on why to pod you know it's
one of the greatest web beings one of
the greatest YJ is because the people
feel like they had a connection it
wasn't just a facade that you've seen on
stage or you know on TV people actually
felt like you know it was a part you
know what she was going through and you
know your worries any just life in
general you know I said you know what
what better way to start that rather
than you know giving a Marvel name
I don't know why a missing person my
songs are personal I do shy to make a
universal it's a good long time to
figure that out you know not stay just
in their warm box just Lander the world
is listen that there is such a thing as
perfection you know because we're all
human we're all technically imperfect so
how can we ever achieve perfection but
what I can I will tell you this that
I've always been a big believer of
professional excellence
and that's what I try to achieve I know
I can never get to a point where I hit
perfect shots every time and I just want
to become the best I can be and that to
me is professional excellence
it doesn't athlete like you Tiger Woods
Michael Jordan Diego Maradona what do
you have that at the end of the day you
become bigger than the sport itself I
don't think we're necessarily bigger
than the sport I think that we've had so
much success in the sport and I think
it's in the way we've done it whether
it's through just pure dominance or
maybe someone may have a more flashy
personality as well as dominating some
people or let me do it differently than
anyone's ever seen it done before in the
past and I think that's where I think
people kind of gravitate towards what
what Messi and Ronaldo are doing now in
soccer it's just phenomenal but two
different ways to different ways of
doing it right and then you have Jordan
coming into the league he did it
completely different than anybody else
and then when I came in into golf I done
differently because no one had
trained that when I were lifted weights
no one ever ran ran miles to ever do
just wind sprints
no one ever biggy those things in golf
so I did it differently and I had a
success doing it differently and I think
that's what people sometimes see and
have gravitated towards Tiger do you
ever get tired of hearing this do you
ever get tired of people watching you
asking your questions you're 18 years
old there's gonna be a lot of people
expecting a lot of big things out of you
well that's fine they can expect all
they want but I've always had this one
bonus to myself to my personality my
expectations are so high no matter what
anybody else expects there's gonna be a
lesser than what I expected myself yeah
so that's that's a big bonus and plus I
really don't give a darn what they think
you should learn something from each and
every single round you play every single
round should learn something well
there's one thing it might be 20 things
learn something for you each and every
round and I've done that every run that
I've played I've come back home I've
could take my round I've looked at it
from the mental and mechanical side what
went wrong what went right and apply it
to the next day one thing my dad always
taught me is that tough if you pull out
effort into it you're gonna get results
but you don't put any effort into it
you're not gonna get your results out of
but more probably you don't deserve any
results so I'm gonna get out what you
put into it and one of the things that
my dad always always did when I was
growing up it was kept it competitive
and fun and I'd love to compete so you
kind of just always sped up on that my
whole goal of my entire childhood try
and beat my dad I'm sure Henry will tell
you anything vital
and the nose what's happening you really
can't plan to fight it when you mean the
man you never met before right you just
have to get your tools ready there's a
car stops on the highway they called a
triple-a or whatever and said my car's
broke down what is that lady she don't
know husband well the man comes with all
the tools and he come equipped to handle
whatever the problem is astronaut goes
into space and he pretends that
something happens to just ship before he
take off he gets out and he works on it
he's not looking for something happen
but it might happen so I didn't I just
had everything ready now after the first
round being here with a top professional
a man so great has sold me the Knockouts
and I've been defeated never even
scratched I didn't know really how good
he was so I had to come in actually a
little nervous and with everything ready
after one round of deaths and I found
out that this would tide me out so I
would have to resort to ropes I figured
that out after the first round so I said
I'm gonna go to these ropes and I'm
gonna dismantle everything he can't let
me tie herself out it might look like
he's winning
and if you don't hurt ma'am we'll stay
here but if he should be as great
they say years if he hits as hard as
they say hit when he hit your brakes on
he knocked out Joe Frazier I couldn't do
it knocked out Ken Dodd he was a big bad
job before the fight you remember and
they remember that don't you yeah they
don't say that never he was a real bad
catch of the day right don't forget that
now after I found out he didn't have it
I stayed there but if he had had what I
thought he had had what they said he's
here Ida kept running hoping I wouldn't
get tired you do very strong characters
and pretty much everything you're very
strong decisions do you make those
decisions before you start and then kind
of come to the set with what you're
gonna do and then just in small ways are
you what the way I always approach it is
this that I like to have my own ideas
completely worked out so that if a
director I come to find his working
method is that he doesn't want to talk
to me mm-hmm that I'm not at a loss
there's nothing worse I've seen other
actors who stand and somebody shouts
action and they're just going I don't
know what to do I need they they need
somebody to come and tell them what to
do I never look at a director or
somebody who tells me what to do I look
at it as someone who we work together in
something and therefore I need to be
responsible too so I have to bring
something to the table and say I will do
it this way if you never say it if you
keep silent this is how I'll do it and
I'll give a few different versions but
it would be it wouldn't matter if they
said nothing how many of you feel like
I've made this talk before can I see
your hand please
several hundred times I made it
yesterday you know what I did between
yesterday and today I spent over six
hours getting ready for today you see I
think it would be arrogant if I thought
I could stand up and spit it out just
because I did it yesterday are hundreds
time's that's arrogance that's when
Buster Douglas knocks out Mike Tyson
that's when an expansion team in Houston
beats an established NFL team in Dallas
I dare not look at the people here
several thousand I'm taking over an hour
to that several panels and hours of time
where would my integrity be if I came
here unprepared to make something a
presentation that could make a
difference in your life
there is no way you gotta prepare for it
ladies and gentlemen so thank you guys
so much for watching
that is our mashup for the month let me
know what do you think should we keep
this series that you enjoy it is it is
it one of the must watch videos that you
have to watch this week or was it just
man and you rather I replace it with
something else your feedback is super
important leave it in the comments below
and we'll use that to help us make a
decision finally I want to give a quick
shout out to Mr VIN Bonanno from bond
LLC thank you so much for buying my book
it means a lot to me if you guys watch
it if you want your chance at a shadow
in a future video make sure to grab a
copy of the book and email in your
receipt so we can keep track thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and I'll see
you soon